So RAID stands for
Redundant Array of Independent Disks.
And effectively with RAID
we have several disks
that play the role of only one disk,
in different ways.
It can either pretend
to be a larger disk or
they can pretend to be
a more reliable disk.
Or they can pretend to be
the disks that is both larger and
reliable then any one of the disks.
Now it's important to note,
before we go into explaining RAID,
that each of the disks is still
detecting errors using codes.
So each of the disks,
will know whether it has an error, and
in the overall RAID skim, we will know
which of the disks have an error.
So, we don't have to have
RAID figure that out.
We know that because each
of the disks still has
a code at each sector that is capable
of both fixing some errors and
also detecting even more
errors on that sector.
So, what we want from RAID
is better performance and
we want normal read
write accomplishment,
basically service accomplishment as far
as disk is concerned, even when there
are things such as bad sectors on
some disks or an entire disk fails,
for example because it can no longer
spin, and things of that nature.
So things that a basic error
detection correction code
that is attached to each sector,
cannot fix anymore.
Possibly because we can no longer
get to that sector on the disc.
Not all of the array techniques
will improve both of these.
Some improve only performance,
some improve only reliability,
some improve both.
And these array techniques our number.
So there is RAID 0, RAID1, etc.
And we will look at some
of these techniques.